greetings from podcast Ville its Monday
the 17th the church what's happening now
is brought to you by oh [ __ ]
blue apron blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door
their mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to every anyone
everyone whether you're a chef or cook
part-time cook or not blue apron
achieves this by supporting a more
sustainable food system and setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs how
it works is very easy you choose a chap
design recipe we deliver the fresh
seasonal inspired ingredients and you
cook incredible meals in 20 minutes so
do me a favor check out this week's menu
and get your first 3 meals you ready for
this one for free
that easy check out this week's menu and
you're gonna get your first three meals
for free at blue apron comm slash Joey
again
that's blue apron calm slash Joe number
two I know the holiday season is coming
you're looking at highest and people you
don't know what to do here's not gonna
do it all right you're gonna what you
gotta work smart you're gonna be smart
all right you know what it is to be
smart by going to zip recruited calm
slash Church that's how you right hire
the right person you might not meet what
you you're looking for a guy you're
looking for the right candidate zip
recruiter is the way to go why you're
gonna join tell me why zip recruiter
I'll tell you why because these job
sites they tell you tons of wrong
resumes to sort through that's not smart
their job sites that make you wait for
the right candidates to apply for your
job that's not smart
you know what's not smart using your
relatives to fill in that work while you
look for staff you know what smart
making the lottery they sent a piece of
your retirement plan but zip recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you
it's a powerful matching technology that
scans thousands of resumes so do me a
favor no more playing around go to zip
recruit comm slash Church right now and
I'm gonna tell you what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna let you sign up and you're gonna
find up your candidates go to zip
recruiter
dot-com / Church number three come on
baby it's over everybody wants to make
some money you want to go to the bar you
want to be a big shot you want to make a
little extra money you got to go to my
bookie
why because you win they pay it's that
easy
ever since we started the podcast Joey
buddy who do you know who's gonna cover
but Gregor Kebede I don't know nothing I
mean I don't know I'll tell you what I
do know I know where to put my bedding
at my bookie why because they've been in
business for years and they got great
reviews online that's why my bookie is
slammed with new betters and wants to
give everybody the best service possible
so what I'm gonna do is this visit my
bookie today
that's my bookie my Bo ok ie and don't
forget to use the promo code Church to
activate the offer and when you create
your account you're claiming to a
thousand in free play so go to my bookie
right now Lee kick this [ __ ]
meal you're sitting there watching me
what's happening you bad [ __ ] I
hope you had a great weekend Philly I
want to thank you for coming out DC the
nine [ __ ] thirty club speaking
of DC we got one of DC's favorite sons
here in the house tonight my man Jon
Bernthal thank you very much and it's
good it's great to see I haven't seen
you since we shot that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] movie New Orleans but I was
telling Sean that I walked in when I
landed I went to watch the scenes and De
Niro was you know the neighbor I just
met I told you yeah and he had [ __ ]
them up a little bit like you know how I
was cool trying to be cool with him and
then finally even [ __ ] ello gets
humbled even likes DeNiro the first two
takes he just fell apart and I'm like
wow that's funny that's you know and
then it was my first before my thing
with him I had like two lines and John
came over he goes on Crenshaw yeah so at
least I knew I was home so now I could
and the first take I looked at him and
you see every actor he's playing you see
him in the [ __ ] [ __ ] movie
in his [ __ ] deal until you see him is
Frankie angel and little something like
cut Joey you okay yeah give me a minute
yeah yeah but they're so it's great to
see it's crazy when you look great god
bless y'all all you work late your
success thank you watching it's like
[ __ ] Walking Dead just started a
[ __ ] vow that's show man yeah that
was it that was a special one and then
now let me ask them when you were a
boxer first no man i box with him yeah I
learned how to box from the first dream
no I mean you know you know I've learned
a lot I've learned a lot from boxing and
I think in terms of in terms of you know
with with this with what we do he could
I mean like you know I came up you know
Shawn I can't I can't I can't really say
enough about how much I've I've learned
from him and how much this friendship
means to me you know me and Shawn come
from the same place we met in DC Shawn
came out here first and this
[ __ ] man you know when it went
when you know I was getting in all kinds
of trouble growing up and you know I
played sports I did did baseball
football and you know I ended up I ended
up not being able to finish college
because I was always getting in trouble
I mean one thing after another I ended
up moving to moving to Russia and that's
where I studied acting I lived in Moscow
for a couple years and you know right
before all that you know I knew Sean and
Sean was a professional boxer and
[ __ ] you know I heard Sean's I heard
Sean's interview with you which was
great but you know he's a modest guy but
you know he went to the Nationals I mean
he was a city you know he's an
undefeated pro I mean he's a serious
[ __ ] and the thing also was Sean
you know just you also got to remember
he's a Division one wrestler and you
know not to talk about but in a deeper
darker time in our lives
Sean Kerrigan was the most lethal dude
I've ever seen in my life on the street
and I'll tell you something never got to
talk [ __ ] never got to start a fight
it's not who he is man happiest guy
that's it man but if you want to be a
bully around him it's not gonna work
along life now gonna work doesn't matter
you got a knife you got a gun doesn't
matter it's not gonna work and and I've
seen it and but you know the the you
know one of the things we Sean and I you
know what we I don't want to talk about
this stupid [ __ ] the whole time
what can kind of hate him but what I'll
say is you know you know Sean came out
here and you know he taught did you guys
get into the next action star thing yeah
he did
so I mean you got to understand like
what that was you know he came he came
out here and yo Sean you know in DC
there's no frame of reference you want
to be an actor that doesn't exist where
we're from there's no you know it nobody
really knows what that kind of kind of
means and you know Sean came out here
really with nothing he gets on this TV
show right in the beginning right in the
the sort of birth of reality TV right
when America nada was started and they
wanted to do like an American Idol in
anyway this is my [ __ ] version of
your story so you just deal with the
dude so you know right in the beginning
of reality TV you know he gets on
basically the American Idol but for
actors for action stars and the the
criteria was that you could have no real
TV experience so he came out here just
being a fighter coming out here he
wanted to act he had done some things
back in DC he gets on that show and and
and the guy who gets to win that show
gets to star in a two-hour made movie
aired on NBC directed by Joel Silver
produced by [ __ ] Joe good enough
right but that is a huge gig man for
somebody coming out to LA with no it's
huge Sean gets on this thing and he wins
the whole [ __ ] thing and they had to
put him in hiding so he wouldn't tell
anybody because everybody thought this
show was gonna be the next American Idol
what was doing for I don't know Kelly
Clarkson all these people's kind of do
for these action stars and this dude
just came in and won the whole [ __ ]
thing and to me you know I didn't even
know that he had worn it I just know
knew that he did it for me
that was the biggest celebrity and that
was the coolest [ __ ] I mean I met when I
first came out here I would go to
nightclubs and I'd be like hey man I'm
with the dude from [ __ ] you know next
action started [ __ ] the show I hadn't
even come out but I thought in my idiot
mind that that was you know the end-all
be-all you know and he came and he won
it and they put him in hiding and you
know think they secured holding deals
with him they
I see em came in and and and you know
represented them and and you know he was
poised to be this huge action star and I
know him I know how talented he is and I
know how good he is and I knew that of
course this all made sense they ended up
airing the show much later than they
thought they're gonna air the show and
the show was a huge freaking flop and
they ended up it ended up not being the
American out of what they thought it was
gonna do and as Hollywood as Hollywood
these [ __ ] and again this is my
version of the story but these these
folks as much as they were pumping them
up now they're all turning their back on
him and backing out one after another
after another and all of a sudden this
guy who has this media that you what do
you say meteoric meteorite yeah meteoric
yeah thank you brother
so he's got this [ __ ] rise just like
that they they kind of leave him high
and dry and the movie doesn't you know
the the movie on on NBC doesn't doesn't
do what they thought it was going to do
and so this guy gets a taste of the
falsehood and the [ __ ] that this
town can can give you and 99.9% of these
people who this would happen to would
tuck tail and run what pack would
[ __ ] leave man I've been a
psychiatrist for a year and a half at
home that's it that's it and and and
this [ __ ] because he is a
fighter because he is a fighter he is a
real [ __ ] man and a real [ __ ]
fighter he say hey look man I'm not
letting this thing lick me he could have
gone fought in the UFC he could have
gone and done a million different things
he was undefeated [ __ ] boxer Division
one wrestler and and what he decided to
do is invest and dive into acting school
and to learn and learn and put his work
in he went and did open mic nights every
night I have so much respect for
stand-up comics I'm out I envy you guys
because you guys don't need to be hired
to do to do your art you know for me I
got a you know I got to go you know
grind hit the pavement jerk people off
do whatever it takes to get hired onto a
job I love the fact that stand-ups you
just need an audience and a mic and I'm
so envious of that but what I saw Sean
do is work day in and day out every
single night getting up there performing
somewhere and he went he kicked [ __ ]
ass and he did it now he's got this
great career in both acting and in
comedy and you know for me that's about
being a fighter and it was a huge lesson
for me
it was a huge lesson for me to sort of
you know man for me starting out in this
job was me and Kerrigan meeting in the
mornings 5:00 a.m. going to get [ __ ]
coffee going we would go to each other's
auditions won't let anybody [ __ ] with
each other we would get we get each
other we got each other the work that we
got he would be right there with me
every step of the way and we'd go box in
the afternoons we'd go out all goddamn
night and start the next day and that's
really was that's what being in
California was like for me and I can't
tell you how much I owed to him and how
much I've learned from him and how much
I respect him not before you came out
here you said you went to Russia you
lost
mmm did you take any acting classes in
DC no well or anything being offered no
no man I go to college nothing I went to
college to play baseball yeah I had no
real business be in college I was you
know I was getting in trouble all the
time
getting getting in all kinds of [ __ ] and
then you know in the in the college that
I went to I ended up taking an acting
class almost as a as a fluke and I've
told the story before but you know I
ended up because I'm an [ __ ] I
thought I was gonna be in a 250 person
intro to acting class where I could drop
acid sit in the back of the theater and
just watch movies you know because
that's what I heard that the athletes
did but I was such a [ __ ] I signed up
for the wrong class and ended up into
this intro to acting class which was
with theater majors and it was just 10
of us sitting on the goddamn floor
trying to learn how to act and I'd never
met theatre people before I never I
didn't understand what they were like
they were so different from me and you
know the first assignment I told this
story before so I'll try to be brief
with that the first assignment was to
bring in something that you cared about
and share it with the rest of the class
and I remember the first girl she got up
she had a Blues Traveler CD that her
boyfriend had given her and she's
sharing that with the rest of the class
talking about it and she's crying her
eyes out I'm like this is the weirdest
[ __ ] girl of every like why is she
crying in front all these [ __ ] people
and then the next person had a teddy
bear they're crying their eyes out
talking about it and you know it was
just like a game of show-and-tell on
steroids you know and slowly but surely
was working itself to me and I've
forgotten to bring anything so I knew I
was going on a fall baseball practice
right afterwards I had a I had my
catcher's glove so I just decided what
are you doing that situation I [ __ ]
it I made up the
story about how my mom had given me this
catcher's glove on her deathbed and my
mom's alive and well in DC you know I
mean I'm telling the story I'm [ __ ]
crying my eyes everybody in the class is
crying their eyes out I'm like oh I'm
just bullshitting I'm just doing the
acting I mean that's what and the
teacher this woman Alma Becker who ended
up marrying my wife and I she's an angel
she saved my life man she excused her
class and she pulled me aside she ripped
me apart for you know violating the
sanctity of her studio but then she said
hey man you [ __ ] have something and
you need to audition for this play and
she put me in my first play and III
found it and then when I couldn't finish
college because I was always getting in
trouble and it just wasn't working out
she was the one that said hey listen the
best I went to her and I didn't think
acting would be any different than being
a lawyer being a plumber being a doctor
what are the steps that's how stupid I
was like what are the steps that you
have to take to make that happen and she
said look if I was you if I was a young
actor I would audition for the Moscow
Art Theater it's the best theater school
in the world and I think deep down she
knew she needed to get me away from all
my craziness and my knucklehead friends
and the people that were sort of made I
was doing the crazy [ __ ] that I was
doing with and I ended up moving to
Russia man and I was there for about two
years and you know Moscow in in the late
90s that [ __ ] that [ __ ] opened my world
up it taught me so much about being an
artist and it was the first place you
know to be an actor in Russia it's a
very masculine profession man it's it's
not like here it's not like the people I
grew up and it's stupid you know they
look at being an artist and it's it's
you know it's it's uh they look down on
it like it's a weak profession you know
like it's it's that it's not a
profession of building and putting in
work and craftsmanship and and and sweat
and tears and and you know Russia
you go around they have statues in it on
every street corner of playwrights and
of poets and of actors and being an
artist is is is something that's
celebrated and revered because of how
much work it takes and how how strong
and you need to be and how much you need
to experience life and investigate every
[ __ ] nook and cranny of life and you
need to go live among all kinds of
people they understand that and it's a
brutal it's a brutal school and a brutal
profession and they get that and they
celebrate that and I just thank God that
you know all my sent me
and that's that's where I got to sort of
cut my teeth because that made me who I
there's no way I'd be doing this [ __ ] if
I would we black them since day one
Jesus loved Chicago but the guys that
the guy that honed in the acting was
Stanislaus that's it and that's the
school that school you want yeah yeah my
service like teaching the San
Stanislavski and I remember that then
they came to the United States and like
three of them broke off yes they'll have
Meissner the guy that played The
Godfather yeah in Strasburg yes sir
theater yeah King became like a group
theater and stuff like that which has
always been very interesting to me so
you are considered a method actor
I don't you look man you know what that
is you know the crazy [ __ ] is is you
know acting is you know I don't want to
give a [ __ ] history lesson but you
know when when when Stanislavski you
know for them to take that trip it had
to be sanctioned by the government right
so in 1933 they went on a world tour
with a play called the seagull which is
one of check-offs most famous plays
Stanislavski starred in it and he
directed in it and they went to they
went to Europe I've done interrupt you
and you went to Russia they didn't want
to have act in Russian or they speak
American I'm just so everybody in my
class bo rush and they're all Russian I
spoke English but the whole point was
that if the acting is good I went to go
see the theater every night in Russian I
understood every [ __ ] if it's good if
the acting is good and your plan what
you what you're going for clearly and
with all your heart you'll know exactly
what's going on how to leave you don't
know the language the matter I truly and
your first year there you don't speak
any text it's all about getting your
body right and your mind right and
learning how to play actions with people
learning to connect with people learning
how to build an ensemble with people but
when they were when they were doing this
world tour of this play they it was the
first time ever what acting was up until
that point was presentational so was
[ __ ] going to the front of the stage
and proclaiming to the audience and
everybody looking straight out and the
what Stanislavski did is he started out
the play starts and everybody's got
their back to the audience they're
really drinking tea they're talking to
each other not talking to the audience
and that [ __ ] blew [ __ ] people's minds
realism blue [ __ ] people's minds and
so the whole thing about method and you
know get so like I feel like
bastardizing nowadays it's like all
these people they just want to we're
being a method act
like a Badge of Courage you know like
you know I [ __ ] got my leg bit off by
a shark cuz I'm gonna be in a movie
about [ __ ] fish you know it's like
everybody wants to [ __ ] show how hard
they work but you know for me you know
what method acting really means is just
an absolute commitment to being truthful
you know and and and to not to knowing
it and to understanding and put it in
your heart enough that it's you in this
other person you guys are soldiers for a
story that you're working on together
and it's not about doing a whole bunch
of acting it's not about shershow on
anything it's about being right there
and whatever it takes for you to get
there that's your method yeah I always
loved like when I got here I was this
dirty stand-up comic I don't know about
nothing you go to Tommy Store you do
Tommy and somebody comes and talks to
you one day about being on TV but then I
heard about bad acting so I started
taking acting classes and it was so
weird I took like you take the basic one
like Frank Magna off a gardener across
from toei yeah behind toi there's a
little Actors Studio he was on Monday
nights but he hated stand-ups he liked
me but he didn't like stand-ups in his
acting class because he says we were a
little too wild from so I went over to a
vantage Chubbuck I don't know what the
[ __ ] she teaches over there yeah but she
had the blonde you know Teresa Ron yeah
and she had Halle Berry who would want
to count me awards back the back so I
got everybody in town and I enjoyed it
when I was going on acting class it
showed me how to hustle as an actor like
I wasn't hustle as a stand-up normal
because the the the stand-up world
wasn't responding to my material so I
was getting breakdowns and live I would
pull them off and email them to my
manager by 9:00 or my agent and in those
days there was no computerized things so
I had three agents in my world whoever
called first said so I would call Shawn
carries and Shawn carrying and they cast
in this movie I call you back in an hour
you got an hour what happened no I left
a message go [ __ ] your mother that's it
yo call this guy yo call this guy I
would seek three people and three people
would be pitching the same one and it's
amazing I had three agents at one time
and the auditions I was going in it
taught me what each
agent saw me as I had a gay guy that was
crazy gay up here north in Ventura I
mean telling me about bars and Hollywood
where there's a red light they were all
sucking dick in there I mean this guy
was crazy day he only represents either
actors in New York yeah and he took me
he saw me at the store yeah but he would
sent me for high-level stuff like he was
an agent by himself that would call
casting people like he got me a movie
that it was an extra he contacted the
writer and made the writer write me and
he thought it would be a funny thing and
they wasn't oh yeah like he had been
around that wall yeah you know I guess I
really got into the acting thing yeah
but then it got to a point where it got
creepy how so it was too creepy for me
like I started working with people that
they have to be in character before
thing and don't talk to me and you know
the trailer and then I was like that's
it yeah I'm done with that part of it
you know doctor listen I love the acting
thing I love Stanislavski and I love I
still her having everybody hang a bad
booth feet I know a bunch of [ __ ]
black dudes from Compton yeah that they
put him in a movie with no previous
experience take the fog up the bottom of
a glass
Queen Latifah she came from East Orange
New Jersey look at her so do you
understand my comparison in my head like
I was like this people and then there's
other people but the people who study
like you I see that richness in your
work look me I appreciate you said I see
that but I hear what you're saying you
gotta live like you want to go through
life you gotta you know you gotta be you
you know that's that's what we do we're
telling stories I don't what you did you
get here
I got here but I think 2004 about you
sure do you remember in Santa Monica
I'm fountain right below like the Comedy
Store in that area
there was an acting coach and every hour
on the hour when you drove up a fountain
you would see 40 people in lines outline
lines on the street have said I used to
be but he knows he knows I'd even go
crazy and I'm talking get out of there
you're a bunch of dicks up cause I ain't
gonna do nothing for you
listen in my world me reading on Santa
Monica Boulevard some other Mook
yeah like it just it got too abusive
yeah you know avantage Chubbuck was
making women strip like when you meet an
actress from advantage chubby that's
been there for a year she's crazy
yeah cuz advantage havoc made women do
[ __ ] they wouldn't normally do take off
your blouse to show you you wanna dream
you wanna dream that's it and that's the
problem
I'd really found what you know I never
did like acting classes out here but you
know look versus Russia you know here to
be an acting teacher so many people are
doing it because it didn't work out for
them or because they're validating their
own sort of thing like that they're
staying in the world by taking other
people's money and showing you how to do
it but you didn't [ __ ] do it so how
are you showing you know like what do
you really have to offer and don't get
me wrong I think there's great coaches
but you know in in in Russia the way it
worked the highest honor that you could
get the highest honor was to be a
teacher so if you you know my teachers
were the biggest the biggest most
respected actors of stage and screen
those those were the teachers over there
just it was only greatest NBA teams in
the last 20 years who I wanted the Bulls
who coach the Bulls Phil Jackson did you
ever see Phil Jackson play basketball he
played you want to stick that stabbed
through your heart he was the sixth man
yeah yeah he had no meat on his bones
and I was in the eighth grade I mean why
the old honorable gambling addicts yeah
so we would split five times that's 1250
apiece 15 if you lose yeah and let me
tell you something whatever they put
Phil Jackson we just hang up on each
other like we were kids and we watched
the [ __ ] [ __ ] whole game on the
phone
like and we were like come on they gotta
cover the spread yeah well son hold on
substitute Phil Jackson hang up the
phone you know we blow it he was the
best six man the league he had no bones
talk yeah
just cuz you're not a good player yeah
doesn't mean I believe that you've done
there's a lot of things about me that
I've seen it I've seen guys are not
great comedians but when you talk to
them they have great timely knowledge in
your words they just didn't know how to
express it sure Phil Jackson every time
they put them in I just hung up on
whitey whitey
[ __ ] your mother you [ __ ] bacon me
better Nikhil [ __ ] I thought he was hurt
you never saying that he was hard yeah
Jesus Christ but look what he went on to
do with two teams yeah he came out the
like this for a while huh
yeah so that I didn't mind that there
was one particular guy in town and I
want to give him up he taught me for
like six months and then he booked the
cold case it was the worst episode of
cold case they ever made like he kept
call me when are you coming back never
and I just hung up the phone like I had
the craziest acting thesis I had a gay
guy I had to him and he would coach him
for 20 miles of coach he was the best
game best coach ever he's trying to get
me call backs yeah yeah in those days
when you went to callbacks Travolta was
in the room lovino is in the room or I
can call back he was just show up don't
call back but the actors were in the
room and my hands would go in there and
the sides would shake you remember those
days champ arrogant okay calm down just
readin how it is you know saying like
it's it's such a process but you said
[ __ ] I'm gonna bust out New York [ __ ]
those dick suckers [ __ ] LA and those
dick suckers I'm taking them right to
Lulu the truth that's like going to Muay
Thai land that's like going to Thailand
and following that perverted coach into
the cave but you learn Muay Thai in low
voice I go you know you won't want how
to cook French women in New York but in
France for three [ __ ] is that's what
I respect about you think that you went
to the heart of [ __ ] me manah yeah
you took two years you it was a smart
idea of mine no man I got laid I didn't
really look I was in I just absolutely
you don't wash with the Russia Mike
Swick
you move Mike's with the UFC fighter a
good guy his mother was the consulate or
the ambassador of Russia so he grew up
in Russia oh yeah and one day he was
telling me and wrote in Russian stories
and six hours of how it works in Russia
you pay in every level every look they
don't [ __ ] around you get a dollar
it's not really your dollar you just are
just on alone next thing you know you
got 18 cents everybody has their [ __ ]
handout right
just from creepy stories laughter rocky
end up in New York yeah I went from from
from Russia to to New York I was there
for yeah about a year or so just doing
what I could do and and it was crazy
actually right from Russia Harvard's got
a graduate school for acting that takes
their students to Russia to get taught
by these Russian masters they saw me in
a show acting with these Russian kid
they saw me in a show and they said hey
what are you doing I told him my story
they said hey would you want to come to
graduate school in Harvard and they
invited me to come there I said kid like
like I didn't finish college I I was
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] up and I said yeah
man of course I'll do that so I actually
went from Russia then to Boston I lived
in Boston for two years studying there
and then went back to Russia but this
time as a you know as a Harvard student
how we were delivering well when I was
in Russia I played baseball I played I
played some pro baseball which was like
a joke over there but yeah I got paid a
little bit but then when I went to when
I went to Harvard to just do student
loans and then you come out and then you
talk about a racket you know you talk
about a kid coming out of acting school
and then you know $70,000 and you can't
do a [ __ ] thing with you know cuz
that's the thing I thought I was gonna
go to Harvard and I thought finally I'm
gonna be with the best of the best you
know they see 10,000 kids they only take
these few and these are gonna be the
[ __ ] best and I remember on the first
day everybody got to do their thing and
I'm like oh really this is this is it
you know these are this is this is this
is who's here and you know for a lot of
these kids they never had a chance but
it's a racket they actually closed the
school down there because they were
ripping people off because you saw the
amount of loans that people took off and
no one was making any money in the field
and so that they did they said that the
school was unlawful I think hey let's be
honest it's 2018 and they do it to you
here you get out of college or not you
watch that why were your fraternity boys
and you're like that's what I want to do
I saw it for years yeah when I went to
improv Olympic to take writing classes I
just signed up to take a sketch writing
class to learn how to write sketches and
I was surrounded by kids that were
living off of credit cards that their
dad sent them out here on a tree
like the dads on the biggest tomato
dumpling in like Jersey but said okay
I'll give you a credit card you go out
there and they're at the growling mr.
Advani topic
they're taking voice classes and
everybody's telling them not to go out
on auditions yeah yeah like don't go out
on auditions lady until I tell you to
and they're like okay like I was in I
wasn't even in acting class and I was
taking chances on audition dish I was
telling about the [ __ ] I booked the
first two times I didn't even know what
get on the market was standing on the
mark I didn't know action nothing at
first job I what what they told me to go
to the hair and makeup trailer I didn't
know what the [ __ ] hair making sure
you know poppy Montgomery I walked right
into her trailer man she was changing
and threw a [ __ ] shoe at my headshot
knows it they love my god yeah I took
the extra second closing it yeah that
was a TV show yeah yeah yeah like I
think the hardest thing and I did not
discuss with you Sean Kerrigan the
hardest acting job I never had in that
way that if I wouldn't have had the
chops
I would got fired the first day was a
soap opera yeah that's the hardest thing
so nobody talks t it's like you got the
flu you walked into ABC you sign in they
tear to go to locker room 212 you gonna
walk around 12 some chick comes in and
says read the teleprompter it'll tell
you what Tom what are you talking about
you know the teleprompter tell you when
to come up and they'll say it scene 34
rehearse you go out there and rehearse
them next thing you know though I go
that's what I couldn't all my [ __ ] no
Joe I was like we ain't [ __ ] around
then I had another scene that like stay
closed and I'm like stay closed means
and I want to have what yeah [ __ ] boat
soap operas I shot I was in an eight and
out by 9:30 really guys yeah yeah yeah
we don't play here this is four three
four cameras yes fast-moving train I
would have never and you know I'm like
when you in a movie you go okay action
your line is like I told you that
[ __ ] touch the dog yeah they don't
even play that [ __ ]
yeah they don't even start from my toes
they start with the dog yeah go don't
start from the dog
nothing the top no the dog the dog okay
cut that was beautiful thank you very
much
breathe a ball whistle and your outlet
forgot you can get the thing they take
your scarf off I never saw nothing like
that in my life like I was not if I
would have got here off the boat and
been prepared for been higher than the
soap pop probably I'll find I got fired
my second job from Telemundo they hired
me as a cubed doorman and I went and
talked in the street Cuban and they all
looked at each other and then went out
for lunch and before we come back out of
page from Daniel Hoff saying don't even
go back they're gonna pay you for the
day yeah and they pay for my after after
was 850 back then yeah and they paid for
my after that's always great getting
[ __ ] fine yeah that's yeah I got let
me ask you this because I looked at IMDB
I am to be your Wikipedia how long did
he do Tina and Toni's wedding for I
didn't do that I did the movie I'd
entered the play holy I did the movie in
New York that was my first you dink
about yeah nothing happened with that
looks like did that for one week oh did
you I was in Seattle and the guy came up
to when I need to talk to you and we
want to make you the host of the thing
the guy that's the host in it was
nothing it was like $75 a weird yeah
four shows you got eat shitty spaghetti
and they said just do Wednesday through
Sunday and let us know and Sunday no I
told them on Saturday you ain't gonna
see my Cuban what do you mean we got a
replacement you're gonna ruin it for
what the Tony team is in New York or
he's either Tony's or Cialis yeah I'll
tell you what brother I audition for
that shouldn't DC like three - I wanted
to be in that place and the place if I
get paid to act at that point you pay me
anything I'll do it you know what I mean
it was interactive though the whole
[ __ ] thing
drove me crazy it drove me crazy drove
me [ __ ] out I was like I'm done with
my career cuz I'm quitting this job and
never had nothing yeah there's a [ __ ]
left even Tony yeah yeah I want to see
you think the two years in New York were
you booking anything all right I was
doing like some you know I did like the
law and orders and stuff like that I was
I was I was getting enough that you
to me I was getting enough that I would
go in and I would I would do well so
people would sort of have me back kind
of thing but I you know strange man just
like you I was so green and I had no
idea I had no idea what on camera really
was about I used to wake up every single
morning I get up and at 5:00 a.m. every
morning they do something called EPA's
equity principle auditions where you
could sign up it was an open call every
single morning and for me I just wanted
to get better at our dish I guess it's
like for you guys going to open mics so
I would get up and it's just they would
take the first 200 people and and it's
people without agents so every morning
and you I don't know if they still do it
but you can get there and if you're the
first 200 the door the door opens at
5:00 and by you know 5:30 you've got 200
people there and every single morning I
go and I would just do my monologues in
front of people and for that that that
just to sort of exercise and see what
that was like just perform a little bit
so I was doing that I got a couple jobs
off of that and I started doing I did
Tony and Tina's I did I did a few shows
here and there but then I remembered
there was I really wanted to move to Los
Angeles I was with an agency that had an
LA office and my brother was living out
here my one of my best friends was
living out here and so I told my agent I
really want to come out there and they
said well you don't have enough credits
we can't represent you out here so I
said you just let me know when an LA
agent comes to the office one day calls
me up there's an LA agent in the office
I went I went right up to like an
[ __ ] and I said hey listen you're
saying you can't represent me in LA so
here's the thing let's just go in that
room and let me just do this monologue
for you and if after that I do that
monologue you tell them you can't
represent me I'll leave you alone but I
just want to give it a shot so we go
into the room and I do the monologue she
says you got an age in LA you got it I
went did a play got rid of all the Marty
rosensweig right and I go I I went did a
play up in Portland Maine and when that
was done I was moving to LA and I called
her up and I said hey it's me remember I
just want to make sure everything's six
I'm coming out there she goes yeah you
don't have enough credits we can't
represent you out there I got on the
[ __ ] guy from the [ __ ] monologue
remember I'm like I'm that guy and she's
like yeah you know you don't have enough
credits so I had a ticket out to LA my
brother got me a ticket cuz one of those
weekend's where was like so [ __ ] cold
in New York they say you know you can't
even go outside I call my brother I'm
like what
doing his I yeah we're just getting high
by the pool but God [ __ ] be out there
so bad he sent me a ticket I go out and
I visit him for the weekend and after
the weekend I going out messing around
with them all [ __ ] night and I lost
my credit card and lost my ID so I
couldn't fly back the next day my New
York agent gets me an audition in in in
LA for a pilot I ended up testing for
the pilot now all of a sudden they want
to represent me so I had an agent I just
never went back left all my [ __ ] that I
just never went back
that was it that's it no looking back no
you've been here I have what year was
that that was like 2003 mm how was
business then mm it was rough man I mean
look you know those those first couple
years I mean I remember my my my wife
she was my girlfriend then she's she's
an ICU trauma nurse you know I would I
would come home sometimes and I'd just
be like look baby this ain't gotta
[ __ ] work for me like it just ain't
happening you know it's and I'd be like
you know I'd be sitting there crying in
my pillow you know like this that's just
after all this [ __ ] after all this work
it's it's just not gonna happen you know
and then she tells me about her day of
like scooping some guy's brains back in
his head or telling some little girl
she's never gonna see her dad again and
she basically gave me a look like
[ __ ] buck the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know stop that [ __ ] and it was about
you know there was about a year there
where it was really really rough and and
then you know I started to I started
work now and then I started to generate
any work on your own at least time but
you could you send thank-you letters to
agent I did what you were talking about
I was I was vicious about being on those
breakdowns and I was vicious about I
mean I would I would just go to casting
offices where they were casting things
and even if I didn't have an audition I
would just look the one thing I will say
I was very confident so I would go in
and I would say look I know I'm not on
any list and I know you're not supposed
to see me today but I'll just [ __ ]
wait here and when you're done or maybe
before lunch just let me do my thing
and if you don't like it I'll never
[ __ ] clue this post letter this was
his was easy because I was pre 9/11 when
you could walk in a lot yeah you just
walked in a lot John Boehner and Nancy
googlebots office and in those days I
would get like I didn't give a [ __ ] I
took criminal skills yeah I was working
with actors and I was saying how lazy
are these guys so what is it how does it
work in your world well our age and
submits us yeah and then we wait for an
audition
[ __ ] all that and I was like that's not
gonna work in my gangsta one yeah but
Jersey gangs had told me that a casting
directors movie - their job is to cast a
movie
this guy was like a [ __ ] there's no
way this line yeah you know what a
casting director job is to cast the
movie they ever think about that anyway
enough yeah and I started getting
envelopes I would go on a break now but
see the breakdowns and people don't know
at home it's a service that comes out
that tells you the commercial shootings
in town like not commercials and films
or the commercial shoots yeah there's a
thousand movies that have made that you
don't even see the breaks that they
don't even it's all in-house CAA and ICM
although hire somebody from WME but you
don't see it in those days you got
called in
so it really teaches you the breakdown
also teaches you that even if you're
right for something you don't know how
many times I went to the office and
called and they would say the guy had a
brother-in-law that was perfectly uh
yeah I learned a lot because I didn't
take no for an answer
in those days I told him Dave you're
atomic and you're not up and up at nine
and out of your house don't [ __ ] talk
to me cuz in those days at 9:00 a.m. I
was already I had six or seven yellow
envelopes
I remember going for an audition for De
Niro movie with Marky Wahlberg that was
sold by vinnie colonel you guys know who
Vinokur know is he's a box that won the
welterweight championship at 44 he's
little box he sent us to see our
auditions I would see him an audition so
Vinnie come in did she ever do De Niro
movie yeah he's gonna know who's casting
a cast got New York I just make up a
name John B yeah and before he going he
come back to me and he go what's the
name of that movie again and I go mafia
six it's with this two guys and I would
goof on it I'd I'd go home and he'd call
me and go what's the name of the movie
then the Joe Rogan story it's my Jon
Bernthal yeah
who's in it then they wrote Pacino
everybody call your agent even call me
back my agent can't find it on the
breakdown it was hilarious
but he really did one he really did win
and he was supposed to fight Marvelous
Marvin Hagler
and he booked that dog you used to guys
you to sit with him stories about Sammy
the bull made him fight under a Puerto
Rican name and put a wig on him garden
is that right
all dog he's got if you open up Sinatra
live from whatever the album it's all
Vinnie kernel with Sinatra he's talking
about being in Palm Springs with Sinatra
Sinatra going in the mood for a hot dog
in for hot dog he sent this pilot to
Vegas to get sober and hot dog and he
doesn't he came back and you know really
Curly's a box is like when he came back
he was cooking these hot dogs I did the
math in my head those hot dogs must've
cost $8,000 a piece to go get real sport
boxing at the garden and like the name
of Tito Ortiz with a blonde hair hunt
and that's a natural walk down and
Sinatra look little nose Benny you ain't
no [ __ ] [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] ring right now and Sammy kept
saying you better [ __ ] be careful
he's like he ain't fighting on the nose
fix me and they took him out and he took
him to a hotel and hit him out for the
night and Sinatra had negotiate and he's
got dog as a strip writer oh yeah
there's no video car like forget [ __ ] he
took the script writing class and he
came out here he's his son on one script
he saw two scripts he's no script about
being on the run from the mob and he
went to Canada was a kid that was
handicapped and all he wanted to do is
run up the hill so every day he would
push the kid to run up the hill and
finally the kid ran up to him the next
day he died dog a story that everybody
was in they were having with a bidding
war
but when De Niro watched the movie from
him when Marky Wahlberg this is 98
that's when this guy he's the guy who
any you guys ever see 29th Street it's
an old movie about like a neighborhood
with that who was the Australian actor
for a while that was really hot Anthony
Lompoc no yeah it's a really funny movie
when I Street New York City and he's the
guy like who sent you
no names he's well I saw when I saw him
at the comedy store I fell in love with
him and he's half Cuban half Italian
he's from Boston and Rogan although
guys will say dog his body shop he was
supposed to fight a claw but something
happened he was up next something
happened something we had happened when
he sold the script of De Niro Marky
Wahlberg listen
they were about to shoot on Monday and
he went to a party on Wednesday and
started saying racial slurs about a
narrows wife at a party yeah you can't
and that was the end of that till they
Pam they pulled the [ __ ] movie but
what I want to see that woman
I forget what I made was you ready for
this she was before first of all I
didn't read that was just got off you
ever read for somebody and it's just
god-awful I got I just got here it was
the third time in front of the casting
director was god-awful yeah the next
thing you know before you leave she goes
hold on and she turned around she gave
me a stack of my envelopes with all the
headshots
that was a 18 like I was hitting her up
I mean I didn't [ __ ] around yeah yeah
yeah your job is to cast the [ __ ]
movie my job is to book it my agent says
I can't come in here cuz I don't have
enough credits that's great yeah let me
read for you that's what I wouldn't give
a [ __ ] now I advise you to do blue agate
unless telling an independent Dolby yeah
you know you're not gonna get through
the gate yeah did you guys always have
this confidence or did was it I can't
because I can't imagine look all of us
came to LA and like LA is like kind of
scary to come to from the east coast you
went from the east coast to Russia where
you didn't speak the language to a
school where they didn't speak your
language and to now coming out here but
does it seem kind of easy to come out
here to LA I guess not that big like
getting back to the same thing I go I go
back to the same thing like what we're
talking about about boxing and being in
the ring and you know like you got to go
back to you know why you're doing it in
the first place because I'll tell you
right now man you know three three days
into Russia I got a gun point in my head
you know I'd like being in that city you
know seeing you know you know seeing how
far first well seeing the Russian kid
seeing you know if you make it through
that school it's not like schools here
if you make it through that school
you're gonna work like you they see
10,000 kids they take a hundred and then
they cut it in half each year and then
they only graduate ten kids and those
ten kids in their fourth year when they
show up at the theater each night all
they do is perform in their fourth year
and when they show up each night
they're told which of ten plays they're
gonna do and which role they're gonna
play and it could be male or female so
they don't know whether they're doing
West Side Story or they're doing Hamlet
or they're doing they don't and they
know everything they know everything's
stone [ __ ] cold and so you know for
me like when I when I would run into
trouble and when I would sort of even
now you know I mean there's times where
I run up against walls I go back and I
and I think about why am I doing this in
the first place I think about
experiences I've had or there have been
more people on stage than in the
audience and we [ __ ] ripped man we
ripped we put everything we had into it
and you know it's like if you can get
through all those times you can get
through all this and [ __ ] I'm doing a
movie right now
[ __ ] Christian Bale Matt Damon huge
director you know I got you know it's an
amazing opportunity
my friend Sean came and visited me on
set my first week I going right from
Punisher into that and I was I was
nervous as all hell I was a mess I
wasn't myself and he said hey
[ __ ] be you god damnit like be
who the [ __ ] you are you're going in
like this I got an open palm now for all
you people in [ __ ] podcast land and
you close your [ __ ] fists and go in
there and be who the [ __ ] you are
and that [ __ ] totally changed everything
for me on this you know say we're all
human you know and and but I will say
you know for me I had when I look back
when I look back if I saw if I saw kids
sort of in my position when I was first
starting I would say you have your
[ __ ] goofball man you got way too
much confidence I mean I would I would
go in and I would do things that I would
never advise somebody trying to be an
actor to do I mean I just I literally
would walk into any room say anything
say I could do things that I couldn't
necessarily do I was just balls to the
wall there was no there's no way you
were gonna tell me no no way and we have
this converse is a recurring then cuz
last year I started going back to open
mics I was a little disillusioned with
stand-up you know because you started as
a hobby and then one day it becomes a
business and that just throws everything
off you know like there's a script that
you really want to do you love the
director you love the material but
there's no money in the project and your
age is telling you that you got a movie
when I tell you about there is that
beige yeah
yeah but you don't give a [ __ ] day to
have them up yeah you really really want
to do this movie so I it becomes a
business and it sucks it sucks being on
a stage you don't want to be on it sucks
to be in a movie you don't want to be in
and I'm sure you pick movies that said
what the [ __ ] am I doing here after the
third day you know my kid's gonna eat
next week that's it you know your kid's
gonna be you next week you know I
started going back to open mics and I'm
looking around it's like if you went to
acting class right
have you told me next week I'm going to
the $100 a month acting class which is
the bottom of the barrel and if you sat
there you never look around these people
and say I was every one of these people
I mean no comedy for 27 years so I am
every one of these people I want to know
what kept you going that fourth year
that's the question now after 27 right
even the podcast two weeks ago I broke
down the first 10 years of comedy
because I'm still looking for the a
slight who the [ __ ] told you that you
had a chance at like I would stand up
every six months I was like what what am
i doing yeah I'm living in a basement
I'm barely paying my bills I'm barely
I'm barely surviving and then a
headliner tells you hey man that was a
great [ __ ] those rental things man it's
like okay that's it the bro that's a
[ __ ] you were killing me in the back or
you're at a club and a headliner laughs
or next thing you know I have - season -
you wanna go on a weekend with them
those little things and then they go
from being what a month yeah that's it
the two about there you're like I'm
still not making a living you know and
then they go to for month you know but
that was my main question like hey I
want to Anthony Robbins to [ __ ] go
into the mind and let us know at the
five year mark what gave us the balls to
go you know what I'm gonna give this
another year yeah like for me I kept
saying six months and then I would be
the commercial or Mitch he sure would
give me an 11:30 spot in the main room
or it was always something that's why
the [ __ ] you're doing in the first but
you says
while you're doing it you know I mean
like for me man you know the experience
of going in there even if it's an
audition I never got but going into a
room and knowing I got every
[ __ ] in that room and they're
feeling something that's why we're doing
we're not doing it for the money we're
not doing it for anything else and how
blessed are we that we get to live a
life that our our entire purpose is to
go after something that will never
[ __ ] get will never [ __ ] get there
and it's not about some crazy journey I
mean it's not about some destination
it's about getting there it's about it's
about chasing something out in front of
you that you you'll never attain but you
can always get better you can always
learn and you can always [ __ ] fail
and and you're really lucky to have that
you know most people don't get that most
people don't get to throw everything on
the line and have that written for what
you guys do going up there and [ __ ]
just it you can [ __ ] bomb and
embarrass the [ __ ] out of yourself every
night man I thought I would go watch him
in the beginning wall I would be a
nervous [ __ ] mess and this is and let
me tell you something he will beat the
[ __ ] out of everyone in here and it
didn't matter it didn't fit didn't
matter at all I'm Lance [ __ ] Sean
Carey that's my it didn't I was so
nervous for him I was like oh my God
look at him up they all [ __ ] he would
start like I don't know I'd okay that
was okay and you know people would laugh
and I would people wouldn't be laughing
or people would be talking I swear I was
gonna good [ __ ] locked up again I was
gonna kill them for [ __ ] talking
we're during his set you know what I
mean it's good and I and and you know
but look every time you step on set
you've got that you you run that risk
every take you run the risk of [ __ ]
failing and that's awesome it's a lot of
people don't get that man a lot of
people don't get that [ __ ] all the money
[ __ ] all the other [ __ ] that's why
we do this you know when I when I was a
kid I used to read this book and the
doctors off there's a Babe Ruth book and
and it was like a little [ __ ] cartoon
book and I remember there was this
picture of Babe Ruth and he's fat as
hell and he was leaning up against the
the the ball field and he was eating a
hotdog and he was talking to some kid he
say hey kid I got it all figured out he
said was that he said I get paid to play
baseball and eat hot dogs and that stuck
with me man I was like wow he gets paid
to do the two things he [ __ ] loves he
baseball or [ __ ] eating hot dogs and
play baseball you know I mean and
there's something that you know you
you're blessed if you're in that
position where you are we
you are in your journey who gives a [ __ ]
you're on your journey you know I'm
saying doesn't matter no it couldn't be
said I mean that's it's I couldn't
imagine not doing stand-up and waking up
one day when you're 52 working in a
general manager as I got nothing against
the working man I'm just saying that you
didn't go for your dream even if it was
a little tiny dream what a [ __ ] life you
had because you lived your life scared
if you knew it if you know me some
people they don't you know like I think
some people's dream is to you know who
knows what somebody's dream is you know
what I mean some some people's dream is
to raise a family some people's dream is
to travel the world some but if if
you're sick enough to have a dream like
this one you better [ __ ] go after
with everything you got you better
[ __ ] good because if I think you're
right I think if you if you pull off on
that if you take your foot off the
accelerator on that you know you never
you know you'll never and who I look I
don't know because I haven't done it but
but I I think that I think that the
thing that we fear is [ __ ] I just I just
didn't give anything here I just I just
I just didn't leave it all on the table
and that's that that's not you know it's
like what DeNiro says in Bronx Tale you
know wasted Talent man nothing worse no
bigger tragedy you know I mean so you
putz till around this town until walking
then you think Walking Dead was
beginning you know man it was really two
things sort of happening in unison you
know you you know up into that point I'd
gotten into a lot of trouble growing up
and I I just was like you know really
you know I come from a family both both
both my brothers are my blood brothers
are tremendously successful guys and I
was just too [ __ ] about the family you
know and and I just couldn't get
anything right I found this thing
there's finally something I was good at
but you know when I came out here even
though life had tried to teach me every
less and I I've been locked up I had
been [ __ ] beat beaten up I've been
jumped I've been all this crazy [ __ ] got
kicked out of schools what I found this
acting thing I really found purpose and
you know but I will say it was a time I
left me in this [ __ ] were
running around the city like wild
[ __ ] and you were roommates at one
time I mean we basically I mean we
really I mean we were with each other my
dad
no he was still roommate right down the
street but I mean Jimmy times were crazy
back then I mean we were really it was
fun it was crazy I mean it didn't matter
what hour of the day somehow I mean I
saw this guy beat up some guy called
himself a paratrooper he beat him over
the head with a [ __ ] magazine at 6:00
in the morning out in front of a coffee
shop in Venice I mean it was like you
know our best friend got stabbed in the
stomach and you know we're delivering
him to my little brother who's a doctor
in the middle of the night like this is
all happening while I'm going and doing
movies with Roman Polanski and Roman
Polanski and and Oliver Stone I mean
like crazy [ __ ] was going on and we were
just going a million miles an hour and
then on July 3rd 2009 you know we used
to have this we used to do this party in
Venice where I lived up on my roof I'm
really good friends with I got Charlie
tuna and guys from fishbone there's this
great band called House of vibe and they
play Wednesdays at harvelle's it's sort
of like the local who's who of the the
Westside hip-hop scene and they would
play on my roof every July 4th and
there's a crazy part everybody eating
mushrooms and just having the time of
their life and the night before that
party I just needed to get away for a
second I was walking my dogs I'm walking
down the street and I see there's like a
house party these you know these
[ __ ] in this party and there was an
old couple playing the didgeridoo right
and that they're sitting there and it
you know a man and his wife and I see
this one guy and I just [ __ ] lock
onto this guy and there's just something
about it where I where I just couldn't
take my eyes off I was with this group
oh everybody's all [ __ ] up he was like
the ringleader and he goes up to this
whole woman who's playing the didgeridoo
right next to her husband and he puts
the didgeridoo on his dick so it looks
like she's blowing his you know there's
something about that that just [ __ ]
pissed me off so much and I'm just
looking at him and then all of a sudden
he locked onto my dog and it was crazy
cuz I'm like 20 yards away from him and
he but this dog right here he calls boss
over and you know boss
runs over to him right and he's holding
her so I called boss back and he held on
to boss and there's something about my
dogs and and my family and my friends I
just like I can't I can't take that [ __ ]
man it was a different time in my life
so I went over and I grabbed boss from
him and and and the guy goes hey man get
your hands off my dogs and he's got all
his friends right there right and I just
looked at him and you know I still just
had a real coldness in my [ __ ] heart
man and I grabbed him and I started
walking why I said come on boss
and he said I told you not to you know
grab my dog he his buddy start following
me pushes me in the back and I turned
around boom and I just hit him and you
know at that point in my life man we we
were just we're getting street fights
all the time and all the [ __ ] time he
was right up the street I hit this guy
he gets knocked out standing up crashes
his head on the pavement he's [ __ ]
out his buddies jumped me I'm trying to
fight them off me they get on top of me
all of a sudden Kerrigan comes run so I
don't know how the [ __ ] this guy heard
about it but carrying comes BAM and like
he's trying to rip dudes off and then
the police come and it's this huge mess
man and when the thing gets all broken
up there's one guy you know lying in a
pool blood and they say who did this and
and it's their party so me and Kerrigan
are handcuffed on the side of the on the
side of the road and they're all pouring
on me pouring beers on our heads because
it's all their people you know and
anyways long story long story [ __ ]
long they ended up taking me away
because the guy wasn't waking up they
put him in an ambulance she still hadn't
woken up before five minutes later and
I've been in trouble my whole life and
and and you know I'm down there now and
um you know I had a career man I was a
series regular on a few TV shows I'd
done you know 12 15 movies and I'm
sitting there on this bench in the
Pacific Division and you know all of a
sudden I remember being locked up when I
was a kid because I'm in a situation
where I'm I'm handcuffed to this bench
and you know they got the wall right
there so you can't even move to one side
or the other and I had to piss so
[ __ ] mad I couldn't believe I'm at a
situation and when I piss I can't go
piss I got asked anybody permission he's
not gonna let me and these cops are on
me hey if he doesn't wake up that's it
[ __ ] you know how they are does
he in my ear if you don't wake up you're
done and I knew man right there on that
bench I said to myself look man this is
gonna go one of two ways but if he
doesn't wake up I'm going down and I'm
going through that room that way and I'm
done man I'm done with family I'm done
with friends and I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be the devil I know what I know what it
means to be locked up in California and
you ain't getting out of that clean and
I'm ready to be that guy I'm ready and
it was it was a scary feeling cuz it
wasn't I wasn't scared it was peaceful
I'm ready to be that guy but lord if you
can just wait this guy up like if you
can just change this I am done man I'm
done with the [ __ ] I'm done with the
drinking I'm done with the messing
around
commit to my lady I'm gonna commit to my
work I I'm gonna be about making a
family and I'm gonna trim all the fat
off my life and I know I should have
learned this lesson but I need to learn
a rap but but I've learned it now if you
just give me a shot and looks sure
enough this guy ended up waking up he
ended up
he ended up suing me for a whole [ __ ]
ton of money you know exceed I just done
a Night at the Museum to which they
[ __ ] put my face on the poster so my
posters all over California he saw it
goes that's a guy that knocked me out so
now he assumed me for two million
dollars saying he's got vertigo and PTSD
and all this [ __ ] and point being
man right after that is when I was faced
with this situation where I had an
audition for Walking Dead and July 3rd
2010 one year later I was on set for
Walking Dead I got married right after
the first year Walking Dead that's
really what my life changed in every
single way and I started working
different start behaving differently and
and I can tell you man I really you know
something Sean says all the time man and
I think the what the biggest gift you
can hope for in in this world I don't
mean to be you know preachy man but I
think it's peace man if you can find
some peace a peace of mind I got nothing
left to prove to anybody anymore man I I
have real peace I'm in love with my wife
I got a I'm in love with my kids I'm in
love with my career and I got the best
friends in the world and there's no part
of me anymore that needs to go out and
be be the guy there's no part where I
where if I see some sort of brand of
injustice I need to insert myself and
say hey man don't you [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] now don't get me wrong
you're not gonna mess with my wife
you're not gonna mess with my kids and
my friends but I'm not going around with
this this you know I think we're
confused man I think we're confused that
we feel like as men we need to go prove
ourselves all the time and we need to
assert ourselves and to me honestly
there's there's actually nothing less
manly I think than being the loudest
voice in the room and and I and what I
what I came to figure out you know
literally a year later on July 3rd 2010
I remember I ended up writing a letter I
never sent it to the guy just wrote a
letter to that guy that I knocked out
and I remember thinking and realizing
that that was me that and not to get to
tribute but that was me that I knocked
out that was the old version of me man I
saw [ __ ] in him I saw behavior in him I
saw brashness and a loudness and a
disrespect in him that I'd seen
the younger version of myself and I was
done with that guy man I was done with
that guy and you know that that event
ended up that event ended up really
changing my life right there along with
walking dead and I think you don't have
I don't have one with that the other
it's so we're negative turned it into a
positive if you can if you can make it
man I still remember being in a jail
cell with a [ __ ] Armani suit up on
handcuffs on and they just gave me six
years and I'm like that's it it's it's
isn't it just as in and you I went to
sleep you know I just have to I got
sentenced I just laid my head down too
closely put three or four hours I was
done and it took me more years to get
peace but you're absolutely right
there's nothing better than a peaceful
man ever since I shot that Netflix thing
in June everything changed me especially
calmly wise I'm a minute comic because
I'm a piece nut I really don't give a
[ __ ] that I mom don't whatever the [ __ ]
they think it's what I do today you know
and I go home and it's so weird how did
you have a was there a transition period
when peace came into your life that you
forgive something was missing
have you ever had that look man I think
anytime you give up anything the first
thing that happens is there's a big
[ __ ] you know when I when I sort of
gave up kind of being crazy and going
out and doing all these things and you
know I I didn't know what the [ __ ] to do
with myself I didn't know who I was I
didn't know if I could act I didn't know
if unless I was the guy sort of bleeding
out and being the crazies I'm you got it
you can ask Kerrigan I mean I was the
guy man you know I was the guy who's
doing the crazy [ __ ] and anything that
people were down for I was laid man
let's go and when I gave that up you
know that the case of my my deal was I
sort of was under this I was under this
this deal with the prosecutor's office
that I had three years where if I was I
didn't need to be charged and he didn't
need to be convicted but if I was
arrested in association with any kind of
violence it was mandatory ten years in
LA County and those three years men
right after that I just
cold turkey stop just stopped everything
and I didn't know what the I didn't I
was really
scatman and believe in myself I didn't
know who the [ __ ] I was if I wasn't you
know being that guy but you know then
you know that's that that's life man
that's growing up it's like you start to
get something new in you don't know what
the [ __ ] it is but you don't run from
that you run towards it and I think it's
weakness and cowardice to run back to
what's familiar to you all the time and
and I think especially and if you're
gonna be an artist
you gotta run to what scares you you got
to run to what you don't do well you got
a rust doing the same [ __ ] over and over
again and [ __ ] you man
like you got this opportunity you got
this opportunity to be a professional
[ __ ] artist like challenge yourself
oh I love it I know ya [ __ ] on my
dick gets it up there you know again I
always knew you know and it's dumb I
always knew from watching those stupid
YouTube tapes that let his skin and had
something in their head and in the
documentary they said our goal was to
blow the band behind this out and that's
what my goal is now that's as
gentlemanly as I could show is if I'm at
the county store I'm destroying that I
don't care what comes out of my mouth
long walk yeah I'm not politically
correct at all no more it doesn't matter
to me I'm gonna take you into my world
and that's what stand-up is taking into
my world you know not to get too much
into that and after walking dead it
hasn't stopped yeah you know me walking
down crazy because you know we did this
show that was you know look man it was a
zombie show on AMC we got picked up when
you flush read the [ __ ] pilot you
like I'm a [ __ ] serious no man when I
read that posit is the best [ __ ] I ever
read I mean I'm migration for for like a
network show that would have solved all
my money problems it would be that
lawsuit I would have been able to piss
on that [ __ ] will lawsuit it would
have just gone away and I auditioned for
it I got the gig was a show that was in
syndication I would have been set
forever but I knew that I still had this
Walking Dead audition and I read that
pilot and I said that is the best that
is the best script that I've ever read
that's the best pilot I've ever read and
I turned down the thing just to go do
and I didn't my people thought I was
[ __ ] out of my mind but I I went in
and it happened and it worked and and
and you know it was a very humble job
nobody thought it was gonna be big like
it like it was but you know you had it
you had a bunch of people there that all
really believed in it and believed in
the same thing
it was a group of group of pirates man
like badass badass actors badass crew
you know way out in the [ __ ] woods in
Atlanta you know there's no trailers and
no crafts sir you're just out there
people getting bit by spiders and snakes
and [ __ ] like that and and it was just
great if it's just it was it was it was
lightning in a bottle and then it blew
the [ __ ] up and next thing I know I'm
getting killed off it so then bring back
all that fear and of course you're a
[ __ ] loser that's what you deserve
like this was that this was the fastest
you know rise and fall two years and I
could have another syndicated show yeah
you feel like that guy that turned down
friends that's it [ __ ] guy that walks
around I turned down for it really shoot
yourself you should next the next aboard
day that's it you sure you turn down
friends you dumb [ __ ] that's it I didn't
like the creative freedom really [ __ ] it
shut the [ __ ] up
but it's a blessing in disguise best
thing ever again something happens as a
new we now you're like me every time you
do it like every weekend I swear to God
every weekend as I'm getting on the
plane to come home I'm like I guarantee
those people gonna call the club and
they gonna cancel me at the next gig I'm
going to as even though I sold out the
room yeah
even though I killed them in my mind
yeah I must have had one bad set one
night I didn't notch this together I
always think it's the last jr. yeah yeah
but you got mean look man I've even
that's an active do you feel that 100%
for three days you're like yeah ask him
what I was like that first week at this
job I was you know I was a mess it but
but I think that means you give a [ __ ]
you means you care and you you you
realize and look man you know the
hardest thing for me is I got three
little kids you know that I love more
than anything in this world they and I
mean anything I I kill for my die form
and and and I'm away from them so much
because of my work and I'm putting their
name on on my work that's that's that's
what their daddy's building that's why
I'm not around
so I sure as [ __ ] I think about every
time before I start you know when
they're older and they go back and they
look it's not because I was doing some
doofy you you know you know [ __ ] man
you you will see that I was working my
ass off that I'm sweating my ass off
that I was given everything I
if I'm away from them I'm not out in the
club and I'm not right no I'm not man if
I'm got to be away from them I gotta
pick up all that move up it's get away
from mercy that's it I'm sorry that's
all I know you move easily get to a
festival and I know it's gonna be great
but you want me in Marina del Rey for
three days on your cuff
I got a she's gotta be karate or four
that's it I take it a bully buster
reform swimming at 5:30 and there's
gymnastics and that is you know I live
in this area here where people send
their nannies yeah to karate is a couple
kids a bully buster that the kid a lip
pulls up where's the parents here I'm
the piece of [ __ ] from Jersey they grew
up with a single mom my mom's bought a
coke and drank yeah well my mom went got
involved with everything I did you know
family you came and drive the kid to
karate in no place I'd rather be no
place right so when me you know it's
times I'm on the computer and I'm on
fire I'm gay good I'm stoned put my
finger in her ass
Yoga Yoga [ __ ] and I'm typing I'm going
nuts and she just walks in yeah puts a
leg on my left hand goes Daddy about
something superhero hi
there's no hold on let me write one more
paragraph yeah yeah for this dissent so
I hold on let Dad do this yeah and I sit
there I put YouTube on for her I said
you know what whatever money I could
have made that Thursday night in
whatever city yeah can't make up for
that hour sitting there cuz after 30 min
to I I can't get this hour back yeah
yeah you're never gonna get it back now
and I know for me to be away from mercy
it just takes a lot like tonight I pick
it up we got two podcasts today and say
I pick her up at 5:30 we go for pizza
tonight nice lemon pizza then we stopped
at yum yum donuts I told her I get her a
donut tell me Danny give me the blue
ones when you sprinkle sit there was a
movie about bumblebees it breaks the
whole thing down and God forbid I'd look
away at the clock yeah yeah oh she'll
know bad and she'll turn you see ha I
got one of those
time to laugh hey so you have to watch
it and she'll look back at you daddy
that's the guy I love that and that you
cannot you know you look at uh I'm sure
you've met movie star sons yeah and look
with the kids on life
there was no attention yeah there was
Guinness and premieres and you're
special you go to the front of the line
cuz your daddies and movies but there
was no real hanging out you know I
respect you man thanks your brother and
was fronting of thousands in one way is
just your passion for comedy your
passion for acting how you treated me on
the [ __ ] film
man that movie man that movie and it's
great that's it that he's coming today
that Pete's coming today you see yes you
know when I got the audition for that
yeah I look you know you get an audition
I got it from Dave Secor alright the
best and then I drew with the same age
over Wow oh nice Dave see who used to
wear bowties he's the best gay guy in
the business purple ones like I'm here
and he called me ugly Jose they called
you in and I did the longest your heart
for Peter Segal when I was doing an
Eightball every two hours
in fact the producers pulled me aside
one day they're like you gotta give a
breather on that film on that for the
longest your on long his yard okay
looking with dr. ah they lose something
was up at which to me and [ __ ] yeah you
know and they said we got to give him a
breathing they're not the premier Pete
see you I had a couple cocktails in him
and they came up to me goes you weren't
my first choice nothing you know you go
[ __ ] yourself he said they had a
separate us at the pub a really good
that was Howard I knew he didn't like me
because when you do an Adam Sandler film
you got two directors you got the
director and I had him yeah and I went
with Adam I had to go what Adam Adam was
the one that hired me so me and Pete had
this never again they didn't get smart
didn't call me in and then and when I
saw the movie I am be beaten and Pete
was it he was a director I go I'm not
going down there I'm not gonna get it
yeah and then [ __ ] I go who the [ __ ]
is he to tell me if I
kill it he's got no choice that's it I
went down it killed it went back again
verbatim and I told the casting director
it was Puerto Rican at the time he visto
Puerto Rican no I don't four years I
just told him about I pulled him beside
if I talk to you for saying I don't
listen now Pete when did the longest
shot I had a lot of problems but I took
care of those problem cuz we have a good
job from he knows we talking about it
was Pete who called you
so that was L like it was so after that
I confronted him on the set a little
longer shot that we spoke yeah a few of
the podcast I told him he's got a he's
got a great Twitter and he should come
on so he goes you know I'm coming out
today nice but no we have a great time
shooting then then did you say goodbye
to how it did did you think about it
DeNiro on that yes yeah tell me about
that I got it I you know he was was he
like a human for me came in the first
day and I did that one scene where he
goes are you by train or something oh
that way then the second scene was with
you yeah when you interrupt us and he
kept calling me a fat [ __ ] I did I
retake he kept going I'm sorry
yes oh he's so sweet yes I won't use
that word you got offended I go you
butter [ __ ] use it yeah and then I
have a scene where he was jumping rope
don't bust his balls of others to murder
yeah and then there was the last scene I
shot when it was the best because I
loved Cool J kept calling Benjamin
buttons yeah yeah yeah saying you
Benjamin buttons looking [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] haha that's what he fires
whatever yeah but I think as I was
leaving that night I went to his
assistant yeah first yeah his trainer
sure and that's something I learned
yeah that I walk soon as I left that
movie I started doing yeah you know
after after he did Raging Bull he hired
that tracer was the offensive he or he
was a strength and conditioning coach of
the Jets right so DeNiro hired him for
the summer to be his coach for the
Raging Bull to got him into physical
shape and he's worked for De Niro ever
say yeah so great guy great guy so to
get to De Niro you kind of had to talk
to him and then they start but he
started talking to me direct
you know I play you know when you talk
to their own or anybody like that your
heart to break it inside you feel like
jerking off and putting it on your face
you know I'm saying you just want to
jerk off in your cup like I'm talking
through there I'm Peter Pacino I'm
talking to whoever yeah and then you
just because you realize they put their
pants on well I gotta touch that man and
he had like this great demeanor to him I
he was Robert De Niro but it didn't give
a [ __ ] I didn't call him Bobby you know
it's the rest of these jerk-offs I
didn't know that [ __ ] yeah I don't not
the premier he was sitting in front of
me yeah he just fell asleep three movie
[Applause]
that's so good my buddy kept going
should we wake him up now hey these
extra lights right the end he didn't
remember the lyrics yeah so now at the
end we'll go out with that wig twisted
and he had the teleprompters they'd be
singing New York New York and he going
was he at all just give this pay the ad
yeah don't expect much here's the ad
just do what you do yeah you know he was
I met him I saw his social disorder he
has a socially shine man and once you
see it you feel better about yourself
because we all have I worked with him on
analyze that okay and that's what The
Sopranos were very hot and we shot on
that block okay so all the New Jersey
Italians like huh and all this [ __ ] and
he walked out of his trailer onto those
80 people and he just slammed the door
you say I yeah yeah and that was it like
they he's [ __ ] had the comfortable to
people away I realized his social but no
I had a great experience room yeah I
loved it man I loved him you know I
played as his son in the movie and the
only reason I did that movie obviously
was like you know I just done wolf of
wallstreet all of you know when I heard
I could work with him and I'd have
scenes with him I'm like I'm [ __ ] in
I'll do whatever I can to do this and
you know we're not there same as you I
really wanted to give him his space you
know everybody's kind of around him I so
much respect for him you know cuz
between takes he's just stands on his
mark and he's you know I mean that movie
wasn't exactly [ __ ] you know I know
nobody knew you know but like he just
but you know he was [ __ ] put everything
you had into it and and I so much
respect for him and
it would just use one of those guys you
know you meet him and that sometimes
they turn out to be just such a [ __ ]
disappointment he was just everything
man he was everything for me and I
remember when the when the film was over
and you know we'd gotten close we had
gone on a couple dinners and he had said
some nice things sort of towards the end
and I remember on the last day you know
I went up to him and I said you know
it's gonna be very hard for me to say
goodbye to you and he said you know I
said maybe I could you know I could come
say goodbye when this is all done he
said yeah yeah and and again I went to
the assistant you know and and they had
me go to his trailer at the end of the
day and I was sort of waiting outside
I'm pacing back and forth like how am I
gonna say good but he's my idol you know
and I'm like pacing back and forth
outside the trailer and they're loading
up and loading up and then these three
guys come out and they come over to me
and say okay pops Bob's ready for you
you can walk on in I walk into his
trailer it's just him in there and he's
mixed two martinis you know when I go
and it's just him and me and and I said
you know you know listen I just want to
tell you you know I've never said this
to you before but you know you're my
favorite actor and I said look like I
got a lot of trouble in my life and and
you're the real reason why I am an actor
when I saw the kind of roles that you
played over the years and I saw that you
could do that I realized that there was
a certain kind of energy that when I
tapped into I only got in trouble if I
tapped into that energy like you did I
could actually make a life for myself
and now I got a life and I got a family
and I got a career and I and the whole
time it's like it's like I was literally
spinning he wanted nothing to do with
this guy was making him so uncomfortable
he's like pushing me away and I said
look no no no listen mister denier I got
to say this I got to get this off my
chest you know what I mean and he just
he did not [ __ ] want it you know what
I mean and I was like I got to say it I
got to say it and then I said you know
and that's just you know Bob De Niro the
actor but now I've seen you and I
consider you a friend and I can't
believe your work ethic I can't believe
how committed you are you know you use
so much of a better guy than I ever hope
to dream you know I'm just kind of late
and I'm crying like a little [ __ ]
baby you know I was so bad you know he
just wants it to end and wants it to
just stop you know I mean so then it
finally ends you know what I mean and
like I wasn't looking for anything back
I didn't want any you you know I didn't
need your dick now suck mine I wanted
nothing you know I mean I just wanted to
tell him the [ __ ] I just want to get
this off my chest I thought I never live
so if I didn't tell my idol that he's my
[ __ ] Idol and then he was better than
what I thought and so when the
conversation was over naturally it just
sort of fell into this awkward silence
cuz now he's got to say something and
he's sitting there and he's looking at
me and he's like you know we do these
things and then the end he didn't mean
anything by it but you know he just
couldn't you he didn't want to engage
and I you know I felt so bad for kind of
putting him in that sit cuz I was all on
me man and I wasn't looking for anything
back it but it's that social you know I
see it with a lot of great light like
we're not in that you know it's like
yeah and I'm sure it's the same with
comics too you can get in front of room
you get in front of a room and just rip
the [ __ ] place down but I'm sure
there's some times you're out with your
your daughter you're out you're doing
your things you know you're not you
don't want to be the [ __ ] emcee you
don't want to be like that's it's two
different things and just because you
can do one doesn't mean you you can do
other sure schmuck doesn't mean you want
to do the other and I could tell man he
just he just wanted to move on and get
going you know what I mean and and and
and and there was no lack of love and
what he said but I said what I needed to
say when have you bumped into him again
I have not bumped into him again no no
but he's you know IIIi have bumped into
you know mr. Scorsese and you know other
folks I've worked with and he's always
passed along you know very kind you know
he was very very good to me he was very
good to me very kind to me
how was my man in Sicario I was which
one the Spanish dude
but Benicio yeah [ __ ] best he's the
best in the world that I [ __ ] love
him I mean look man I worked one day
with him and then in the scene I just
come off of this movie fury where
they're you know we're eight months in a
[ __ ] tank you know not showering
[ __ ] you know Shia LaBeouf [ __ ]
you know pulling out his [ __ ] teeth
and you know we're all like going madmen
in this [ __ ] movie and pushing each
other and you know throwing throwing
bottles of piss at each other when we
feel like the acting is not good so I
came from that world right into two days
on Sicario and I remember him doing the
scene with him and Josh Brolin I'm in
the back of the car right and the in the
script it says my character tactic is
Ted or some [ __ ]
Ted is crying his eyes out so the scene
starts and they roll cameras and I don't
do anything
and Brolin's like a mean you gotta you
know cry mainly what's good you gotta
start mi got cry I'm like make me cry
[ __ ] you know cuz I'm coming
from [ __ ] fury where that's what it is
and I'm like let's go I'm like a [ __ ]
cruft [ __ ] make me go let's go let's
go come on what were you my [ __ ] and
the cameras wrong and that's how I got
into and [ __ ] Benicio just takes his
[ __ ] finger and grabs me and I'm God
you know and I started playing it you
know like screaming fire and they
[ __ ] you you know and what a [ __ ]
what a monster he is I mean what a great
you know he was right he was like oh you
want to [ __ ] play you want to play
big boy let's go big boy and he just was
you know he's a genius he's a genius and
III love him for that man Allah is one
of my fav another guy who Umbro into
another but I mean I think Brolin is the
[ __ ] best fat American oh so [ __ ]
good American man so good and you know
those are the guys you know I I don't
know it's like for me I still go to
movies for performances you know
directors direct I go see actors actor
Owen if I know Brolin's doing something
Benicio is doing something DiCaprio you
know if those guys are doing something
you know there's there's a list of my I
got to see it I got to see what they're
doing you know if some bro it's not
gonna be too long until you're gonna be
one of those guys thank you for seeing
we'll see and I'm happy you took the
time out of course now I'm such a fan of
the world disease and it may you you do
you do a lot of good man on the show man
cuz it's all [ __ ] heart you guys are
funny no but it'sit's and you brought
the dogs with you when you hit me I was
in a meeting
hello can you spell it out for you okay
okay give me a [ __ ] ear beat and I'm
tryin to say yes yeah yeah and I mean I
love door okay I don't give a [ __ ] about
look I gots a lousy role here whatever
but surely I'll tell you a funny story
since this is your comedy yeah thing you
weren't here Joe Rogan used did you hear
that he had a dog for a while named
Frank Joe Rogan was a saver of pitbulls
for a while he had Frank and then he had
another one guy and then he got a
girlfriend of his that plays the guitar
the girl was a little chubbier and older
and
she ended up killing one of the dogs but
before Frank died I went to the Kombi
store the Tuesday night and this is what
the candy store was men's amant
nobody went down there people had been
shot black Tuesday night was black night
so nobody white went in there it was
really sad that the main room
Wednesday's was maybe 60 people Thursday
was maybe 65 people than the weekends
were the weekends
but were there like on a Wednesday night
saying there was 60 people in the
audience and Joe's coming from somewhere
I'm was set he's bringing the [ __ ]
Frank with him so I knew Frank at that
time and Joe so we're outside I'm
hugging Frank and whatever and next
thing you know they go Joe you're up
next
and he goes Joe can you just hold Frank
for me so I told Frank by the stairs you
know I could have you go up to the belly
room and Joe's on the stage but Frank
could hear Joe's voice and he's gone
nuts he's barking
so finally uh one of paulie's friends
that great guy comes only was Jose and
they're yelling just to let the dog
onstage it's 10:15 at night there's 60
people so Frank I leave morph the leash
he runs he gets up on the stage Joe
gives a bonus stage let's keep it going
for Frank Frank [ __ ] goes into the
ship position it takes a [ __ ] right on
the [ __ ] stage at the Comedy Store
why everybody's are the old it and it
smells like 10 that Iranian right it
smells like the whole original room
smells the stairs in the hallway Joe
taste the dog obviously I'm sorry he
ain't a bad Mouse who eats a good Mouse
I'm saying like what's a bad [ __ ]
Mouse he took like a six-inch [ __ ] on
the stage but it smells so bad
so in between comics they had to come up
like this little Mexican doing this
white manager they had to scrub this
[ __ ] Joe's up there giving 20s out
[ __ ] so sometimes on that's what I
kept thinking about the bugs and take a
[ __ ] this video we're gonna be cleaning
it later
what's uh what are you doing this thing
with Christian Bale how that's all Shaun
it's also got yeah Shaun also has a few
days on it but you've got Widow coming
up yeah weirdos come now I got a movie
with Shia LaBeouf that's coming out and
then this one for Ferrari that's
that's gonna be a big one and then we
just finished season two of Punisher
[ __ ] so Tate said don't forget about him
yeah cuz he said Keith Jardine to you
yes I love that [ __ ] so he was
saying last night hopefully I get our
Punisher [ __ ] I would love to have to
say it's a great you were great be
accounted by the wise bro I watched a
lot too planes thank you you know what
that's always I'm playing a whole thing
yeah both you guys all threes I love you
saw and anytime you have an hour to kill
just wanna talk some [ __ ] or about a
movie [ __ ] yeah please you're more
always one here brother nice but I want
to thank Jon Bernthal for coming in I
mean John you're a [ __ ] Savage
I appreciate you with all my heart and
and Sean and the guy and the dogs I mean
it was a great podcast we had a great
time today but listen don't forget don't
forget not this week I got nothing for
you this week I'm sorry
the following week I'm at the Wilbur and
at the Foxwoods but that's old that I'm
sorry about that but what I do have is
West Palm Beach [ __ ] October 12th or
13th to the 15th oh go to improv calm
right now that's what I do god that's
all I got for you but now like I talked
about in the front of the show ever
since we started the podcast everyone
wants to know who's gonna cover the lock
who's this who's that I got no idea I
can only recommend the service to my
listeners that's been good to me that's
why I'm urging you you to make your way
to my bookie you know why cuz you win
they pay they got they have in game live
bettin over and unders on fantasy point
scored and the most rewarding player
perks in the business if my bookie is
slammed with new betters and wants to
give everybody the best service possible
if you're willing to deposit after 7:00
p.m. Eastern Time they'll give you an
additional $25 free play on deposits
over $100 did you hear what I'm saying
7 o'clock Eastern Time they'll give you
an additional $25 free play on deposit
over on lost
join now and my my bookie will match
your deposit dollar-for-dollar gotta
enter promo code Church to activate your
offer again
listen I'm playing I'm going with my
bookie again why because
they win you win you get paid it's that
simple but you gotta enter promo code
Church when creating your clan account
to claim up to $1,000 in free play if
you're willing to hold out till 7:00
p.m. you get next to $25 free play by
using promo code Church they had and had
25 to the end so I know that it's church
25 alright so church 25 after 7 o'clock
if it's up to you guys I'd wait till I
have to dinner and take that extra money
and make some extra money and that's the
way it is go to my bookie comm slash
Church you play you win you get paid
it's that simple
one of my favorites and one of Lisa
favorites has always been blue it we've
been working with them for years
lead sell a lot more than I do I don't
like cooking that much I don't think
we're gonna fool on cook but Lee likes
looking at doing the whole thing and it
works why because it deliver farm-fresh
ingredients right to your house you
shoot you choose from Chef design
recipes we deliver the ingredients and
inspire the ingredients and then you
cook incredible meals in as little as 20
minutes let bore a pan do the meal prep
for you making it back to school easier
than ever dinner and as little as 20
minutes quick and easy recipe options
with insanely delicious flavors
perfectly proportioned ingredients
delivered right to your door
skip meal planning and shopping and get
straight to cooking with blue apron
not only that they offer a wide variety
of recipes whether you're looking for
quick and easy meals or full culinary
cooking experience blue apron lets you
choose from a wide range of recipes chef
design recipes and exciting september
partnerships with Bob burgers and a
whole thirty approved
this week's menu check it out crispy
chicken tenders with mashed potatoes
yummy for your tummy and pasta and
creamy tomato sauce listen why mess
around check out this week's menu and go
to blue ape and that great blue ape and
dot-com right now and I'm gonna give you
three meals for free you heard it right
here on the church three meals for free
blue apron calm slash Joey again that's
blue apron calm
last Joey blue apron a better way to
cook and last but not least my all-time
favorite zip recruiter you know what's
not smart job sites that overwhelm you
with tons of the wrong resumes you know
what is smart you ready for this one
zip recruited Tom slash Church unlike
other job sites zip recruiter doesn't
wait for candidates to find you zip
recruiter finds them for you why it's
got a powerful matching technology that
scans thousands of resumes identifies
people with the right skills and
education and experience for your job
and it's actively invites them to apply
who else does that so you get the
qualified candidates that you're looking
for fast and that's what you need you
want to make money it's got to be fast
no more sorting through wrong resumes no
more waiting for the right candidates to
apply it's no wonder that zip recruiter
is rated number one by employers in the
US and this rating comes from hiring
sites on trust pilot with over a
thousand reviews and right now the
church family can't I try zip recruiter
for free did you know when I just sent
free exclusive you ready for this one
zip recruiter com slash Church that's it
just go to zip recruiter comm slash
Church and we're gonna you gonna get
hooked up for free gratis on a Monday
with Jon Bernthal in-studio Lord zip
recruiter comm slash Church right now
and get a free signup at zip recruiter
and get your employee before the
holidays I want to thank John again your
family I want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys I want you to start the week long
strong and don't forget they gotta suck
your dick now or they're gonna suck your
dick later somewhere along the line
they're gonna suck your dick so stick
with it Lee kick this [ __ ] meal